no he lives in her heart he was in
staten island trump live in staten
island
trump lives in uh midtown big trump
building yeah
he doesn't live there no well i think i
think they say he lives there and he
lives somewhere else
i i i could i would yeah i would uh not
your
you're full out of the closet
conservative you know what just let me
be honest with you no let me be honest
with you
i was if you were to talk to me a week
ago i would say
yeah guarantee trump 2020 but i don't
know i went to this concert the 1975
concert and i was around i was around
a lot of liberals and they're a very
liberal band and i was like i like these
guys music i like this guy's message
i was listening to what he said about
climate change and then singing his
songs with [ __ ] great ivan [ __ ]
thunkenberg whatever her name is
like and i was like you know these
people aren't as bad as i thought
you know it's like i mean they're
annoying and i'm like all right shut up
but i feel like i could be swayed now
to vote just because how nice they were
left because they're nice people but i
probably don't
i vote for you know who i do what i like
about your opinions you have a sound
understanding of policy that's why i
like the way you yeah yeah
you don't know based on emotions you go
right for policy and
things that matter yeah like the biggest
the things that matter the most are what
to you
in politics in politics yeah wow guy
you're asking him a question that's
that's a little over his head in
politics um here's what i'll say
i'm a weird guy yeah it's like i want i
believe
100 uh in um in pro-choice
i believe it's a woman's right to choose
absolutely um i think religion should be
100
out of politics i don't think it should
have any effect on anything
um and i also just want the wall so i
don't know
it's just you can't have not the wall
but it's like you can't have people just
[ __ ] walk in and out of here yeah i
understand that america you want the
wall and a catapult for the ones who
who get locked in here that you can put
them over i understand that america's
just lines on a map
that some guy made up jesus that guy's
jesus yeah
yeah jesus that that's a guy
disrespectful
yeah jesus respectful [ __ ] what are
you what are you working for islam now
yeah yeah wow we're gonna have to tackle
this whole episode that jesus and his
mother they made up christ
it was basically an arts and crafts
project with mary mother jesus and jesus
made up a man now you're talking
yeah yeah yeah before you were [ __ ]
playing around now you're getting
serious
yeah that's why you paid attention in
history class yeah absolutely because
you know
yeah because i [ __ ] you know so it's not
that i want the actual wall but it's
like you can't you just want the chinese
yeah yeah right right yeah and that's
basically what about the japanese and
the koreans
don't your fans know that everything on
here is [ __ ] well that's the thing
they do but once in a while new
listeners freak out no nobody's actually
ever said one bad thing it was a [ __ ]
comedy podcast it's a character piece
i'm just kidding around yeah he's just
joking
some of this stuff is true though yeah
yeah yeah some of your stuff is
all a lie guy yeah
he's really gay yeah yeah no no that is
that is true though i don't want the
wall but i just i just you know
i'm i'm all for tightening uh it's like
you know what i don't want a great area
kid
i don't want the wall i think that i
don't want this but i think it should be
a maze
i think they should have yeah yeah i
think it should be a lot harder
how smart yeah you got to be smart
enough to get in here yeah